indignación y reacción inmediata a la
muerte de un joven de 17 años por un
disparo de un agente de la policía el
suburbio parisino donde ocurrió el
incidente vivió una noche de violencia y
tensión hubo enfrentamientos entre
residentes y oficiales del orden que
dejaron una veintena de policías heridos
31 detenidos y cerca de 40 vehículos
incendiados también consumidos por las
llamas paradas de autobuses contenedores
de basura una escuela de música y un
tramo de la red Regional de trenes los
disturbios se extendieron aunque con
menos intensidad a otras seis
localidades colindantes con la capital
francesa Esa fue la reacción en el
terreno vamos a la arena política
durante el consejo de ministros de esta
mañana el presidente Emmanuel macón
expresó la necesidad de tener respuestas
Y que la justicia haga su trabajo el
ministro del interior llamó a la calma y
a la confianza en la investigación en
curso sin embargo
hizo referencia a un vídeo del incidente
dijo que si se confirman las imágenes en
ningún momento se justifica un gesto
como el que vimos por parte de la gente
del orden y celebridad de francesas como
el delantero del país Saint Germain
kilian mbappé o el actor Omar sí han
expresado su dolor y exigido Justicia
por la muerte de la adolescente esta
mañana no se han registrado incidentes
sin embargo el gobierno teme que la
violencia estálle de nuevo esta tarde y
para contenerla desplegará dos mil
policías en los suburbios de París